what if this was your sister are you
gonna do that
so i don't specifically pick people i
just say if there's
the youth already lost and somebody's
putting our video that's gonna make the
situation worse or make the youngsters
feel that's okay
i just sometimes you know into my videos
last two videos of adam i said brothers
this is not a video to adam because i've
already done that i can't be a pirate
keep repeating the same thing
i said i'm talking to you but these guys
sorry to cut you off but it's crazy so
this person was was sending you he was
trying to invite you to his podcast and
be sending you pics of me
or something like that no no adam i
heard that he he is it true
i don't know okay no he didn't send it
he didn't send it to me i heard that
he's
he he did this yeah
i don't know he invites me to his
podcast i might go on my number when he
invited me first look if i was evil
i could have said you know what there's
a beef with them i'm looking for [ __ ]
you shouldn't you should have gone to
that you know what he's doing yeah
i you know what you know and he copies
he copies whatever like he's just an
attention
attention attention he's literally he's
trying to get you to get back to us
this guy's a to me he's an evil guy
because i have
so much stuff on him that i can show but
i never did
you know i never i slim i know something
about him that i can see
you know so much about him he he know he
knew something
he's got pictures of me and he posted
online and even if he did post it of me
and he showed it to the world of me and
the club and kissing girls and stuff
i still wouldn't show what he has to the
world you know because i feel like
that would be messed up with me to do
that and will punish me for
so let me let me give something to adam
here so we have a brother who
by the way i will need to speak to him
but from what you are telling me
that he took a private sin and made it
public yeah
if i was to go and by the way
these pictures and many stuff get sent
to me and you know what i say to them
i say fear allah if this is a private
sin done
subhanallah i do private sins can you
imagine someone recording me doing a
private sin
and putting it out there now i do it
because i say that's a private sin
if i went and picked up on those and i
said hey look at adam
you did it i could have used that you
know they were they they were sent to me
in 2016 2015.
that's when he he posted his picture and
this is why this is why i'm even willing
to like
come in a podcast with you because i do
have at the end of the day i do have
love for you
for the sake of allah as you say i don't
have love for you for saying i do see
you as
i still see you as a good guy even if
like even if you try to do you know
even if you came at me whatever you
didn't show my positives you didn't say
you know what he's doing is good and
well i didn't i did whatever
i did in 2014. i just said you did
because you had so many
people with you as i said and i would
always get mistaken with um
that's diamonds this is the point here
is this adam here i get confused people
come to me you did that video i got my
video
that's not me yeah so the thing is that
when it comes to the private scene i
could have used that in 2015 i was
getting sent stuff where i was like
and i believe most of them the sharia
says bro you know the hasanah issue
you know why i defended them because
islamically when the sharia caused us to
defend someone
i would defend the honor to the death of
me and when the sharia called us to
expose hasanah
we did that so some people came and said
to me brother ali do you know regret
defending them i said no because at that
very time there was no evidence it's the
time to defend
but when the sharia called for the
exposure we went full out with evidence
now when it comes to those pictures i
could have used them and if i was to use
pictures of your private deed
my teachers would have destroyed me they
would have made me do a public
repentance
and they would have told me get the hell
out of youtube because it's a private
sid
that's been released and you are making
exposing this private sin to the masses
and i never even thought of that because
we have
guidelines we follow but when it comes
to so for example
certain sins that certain people do in
public i'm saying look
put yourself in my shoe for one minute
put yourself in my shoe
you can see you deal with the youth on
the ground level basis face to face
somebody comes and goes brother
uh i get homosexual tendencies one
mother called me i went to birmingham my
son is
says he's gay he's homosexual and he
left the religion
one girl comes and says look for example
this guy tricked me and slept one
guy comes you've got the youth in front
of you and you're seeing stuff where
you're like
is this really happening and then sadly
you have certain people let's say fuzzy
troop
or other people who are coming and doing
certain videos pull yourself in my shoe
do you if if you love the the brothers
and sisters
what you i'm stuck in the middle i'm
thinking look if i talk about it i'm
going to be seen as
oh you'll stay chasing for clout if i
don't talk about it
i'm doing you know they say for example
look in in the quran allah says
that the children of israel when allah
told them not to fish in the sabbath
yeah
allah told them you are not allowed to
fish in the sabbath the scholars say aki
they were divided into three groups yeah
okay
there was the first group who didn't
listen and they went and fished in the
sabbath
allah destroyed them there was a second
group who said look you know look we're
listening to allah no fish
no fish yeah and there was a third group
the third group was people who
saw it and were quiet allah destroyed
them too
because if you're seeing someone getting
punched in the face and you're watching
are you not a part of the sin so i'm
saying
like me personally look adam i believe
i don't believe you're evil i don't even
believe you wake up and be like i know
let me cause some mental health problems
for the youngsters there i know let me
misguide people
you don't do that and i don't believe
that that's not you
all i'm saying is aki i'm stuck in the
middle i genuinely saw
people who are beloved to me kill
themselves i'm seeing
i don't want that for anyone so i'm
thinking i'm not saying you're doing i'm
saying
i'm trying to advise the youth and i
just want
the private life that's done my private
life i'm a sinner adam you don't know
the sins i do
brother you don't know maybe i am a
worse person than you
in the context of like we're all our
sinners we're all worse in our own ways
you get it
in the sight of allah maybe you are more
beloved to allah than me but i'm seeing
aki
in my videos while i did never insult
you i never said the doors of jannah
closed while
i didn't even raise my voice at you all
i said was brother this is wrong maybe
that shouldn't be done
may allah bless you i'm your fan i like
certain videos while i
praise you so i'm saying aki if the
problem is that i advise you
like this i'm not trying to be pious
brother my name is ali
but it means nothing yeah i'm saying aki
shall i listen to allah and his
messenger and try my best to advise
people
or should i be quiet
let me tell you something i understand
like for everything you say i i i
believe you i feel like
you do sound genuine and stuff like you
said you're in the middle like you know
what to do but like
i feel like just like since adam made
that mistake right like i feel like
a way if you wanted to come about and
give advice like why not make a video on
just how to relationships itself instead
of just targeting atoms i don't think
like you could like since he made that
you could have just talked about haram
relationship to how it destroys people
itself instead of saying
you know adam's you know you get me you
understand what i'm trying to say okay
that the
the the thing is it's a topic you
understand the topic of action i've done
that after a whole series called the
reality show it's all about her own
relationships yeah
my marriage documentary the first part
it talks about my own haram relationship
i was in a arab malaysia for five years
i talked about the damages that caused
how i overcame it
and all that i talk about i could talk
about my cousin's suicide
i talk that generally but you need to
understand slim look you're a slim
i believe you're a very good friend adam
by the way yeah i feel like being your
real friend brother i'm so sorry after i
saw that
intervention video he is your man adam
while i'm telling you slim
uh even me but if if you see me flopping
stick on me because the thing is because
no no no
they say blood is thicker than water we
say iman is thicker than blood
yeah because our brotherhood aki is
islam
it's not a matter of blood thing yeah um
so what you did uh slim was what was the
following you came what you guys did i
was like
brother you guys were hard on adam i'll
be honest with you slimmer i have to
stick on you man
like you did it out of love but you guys
were yeah you're an idiot and look
that is coming from a place of bad
you're his boys i can't do that yeah i
can't do that yeah i'm doing it
yeah yeah he's your boy he's your boy
but i was thinking
in all of my videos yeah i never ever
like for example
stuck on adam in a way like that and i
know you guys are brothers but i'm
saying
to me when i was watching i was like yo
man these guys are mad
these guys went in i was like i wouldn't
even do that but that's because you're
his brother
but i'm seeing from my point of view um
brother slim and adam
is that watch my videos please one lucky
not to one place i say to adam
you doomed to hellfire you are finished
what is this i don't know
adam in 10 years time he might be i
might be
misguided in five years time probably i
don't know where i'm gonna be so
i don't want to come across as somebody
in the that was in wallahi most people
they don't watch the videos
dina tokyo i do a video we praise her we
did a video saying she was about to take
a hijab he said sister dina
you know what look may allah bless you
you're keeping oh we encouraged her you
know what she did
you know my husband why are you talking
about me i'm like subhanallah
i'm thinking look like like we don't
need a cookie don't give me nothing
the main thing the main thing is with me
is like the the fact that you
you just like not acknowledge that like
you know that we're both
pretty much equal like you're no better
than me and i'm no better than you
and and and a lot of respect for you not
putting my private sense as
this um this guy no no that's what i
noticed you never ever
posted my privacy like what this guy did
never this guy literally posted on his
twitter
he posted in like a sly way like a
sneaky way like saying like oh who is
that
and then you know all it takes is one
person to see a picture on twitter or
something and that's it everyone got it
you know
he's posted pictures of slim like like
he took pictures of slim on the low
naked man
and he posted that on twitter of him
naked in a hotel like
these guys was really really weird so
and no you would never
do something like that what you have
only done
was mention the stuff that i've that was
public which i understand but it just i
just wanted you to acknow acknowledge
that
we're all you know you're not better
than no no
you know so we shouldn't be adam adam
you know when you guys done a video
about hasanat thing
did you guys think you're better than
hasana or did you do it because you care
that this guy took the muslims for a
ride
no no no i i do not think i'm better
than him i don't think he's better than
us but what i didn't like is the fact
that he he was
stealing money he was you know he was
you know to me when you're
stealing when you're like when you're
having
a hobby but you know when you're not
really in the hobby and stuff like that
that's amazing
[Music]
for calling you a phony you are not you
are not phony i take back
what i said when he said phony
and i was thinking you know what i was
like my wife should call me that because
i am a phony like i always i'm on my
phone too much
i do feel like you and um and smile to
jenna and and
so many more more people musa you guys
are good people you guys are good people
but
i just this i guess it was just like a
personal thing to me i don't want you
guys
to always show on the negative and then
when there's something positive you guys
are invisible no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
100 look at them look like like i said
before bro look i think you got me
confused with another another brother
it happens i don't blame you people a
lot of people they go brother
why are you i said bro what are you
talking about bro i don't that's not me
yes some people come here but i'm i'm
not look look look i'm not trying to
throw the brother under the bus all i'm
saying is he's a passionate brother
i believe he is saying his name is
yeah i'm gonna come to that i try not to
mention his name if you've noticed
for specific reasons because look he's a
brother that he's
he's he's still close to me in the
context of i speak to him every now and
then
i believe his intentions are more pure
than mine i'll doubt my own self than
him
he's passionate he just delivery is the
wrong way that's why
personally me may allah bless him
inshallah i don't want to talk bad about
anybody i don't want
because that's why yeah but there's been
twitter of him i think like that exactly
you're like yeah so the thing is look
one of the reasons why i
stopped working with a brother because
you're asking me is because of this very
reason
i don't look i don't like this approach
of
harshness because i was i was boycotted
yeah i was boycotted by the brothers
yeah
did they do it out of evilness no but
i'm a river to islam man
imagine i'm rivert islam to three years
these are the guys that i chew with
these this these are the guys all i know
yeah after that so there's
like double beef going on kind of you
can say
so the thing is what happened is they he
was going in a mad one with a
group of people who celebrate the
prophet's birthday yeah it's innovation
and i said to him look man the attitude
is not right harshness
insulting each other mocking is this
from the prophet does the prophet do
this danny
mocking people laughing etc no so i
advised him he didn't listen
i said brother i can't because you're
damaging the dao up you're making it and
this is the reason why
adam's going on a mad one with me and it
wasn't me like in the context of
yes 100 yeah you're right you're right i
definitely mistake
mistaking you guys together yeah exactly
so
i've seen him a lot but but there's a
reason every time it's reason this is
why we have
you and not him he would have been
probably like screaming and and
shouting because you're right i know
exactly who you're talking about
and how he is he just do like screams
and shouts and like
goes
he said many people intend to do good
but they don't achieve it
just because you have the passion and
you want to do something
you end up flopping it so i know this
brother is passionate he's coming from a
good place
but your delivery if you're screaming
and shouting and
you guys are finished or this that
brother how do you want people to
if the prophet came and said to the
quraish you're going to the fire
aki and you know what allah says this in
the quran if
you was harsh with them they would have
run away from you
allah in the quran to the prophet and i
shall
anna the prophet's wife he said if the
quran came with um
hellfire and heaven like punishment
yeah nobody would have come to the
religion so that's one of the reasons i
stopped working with him because
his his delivery was damaging the tower
i had to move away and say brother no i
don't agree
so you you were like like to me was it
was like
good cop back cop like i seen you you
were more like come on you always be
calm he would be the one
oh matter of fact yeah this all makes
sense he was the one yeah with the
he he was the one that would run he was
one that would run and chase us
yeah yeah he would chase us even when
the security's around he would chase us
and try to grab us
kind of i swear to god i'm not even
joking he would chase
and run and try to one time i seen him
chasing a car and i'm like whoa what is
he doing like he's
coming up in a weight i know as you said
he's passionate
but but to other people i'm passionate
that that look that i have to agree with
you
yeah like i have to agree with you
because i have to be just
he might be watching this and thinking
that i'm i'm not i have to be real
it's good it's not a good look that's
why i personally said brother don't do
this man because
it it doesn't come across right so the
thing is i'm not perfect
yeah and like i said before i believe
his intentions are more better than mine
yeah but the delivery is not that's the
reason i stopped working with the
brother
and sister look i speak to him every now
and then but the thing is
we for example the last i think the last
um
video that we done was mufti meng do you
know how happy we was
when i saw that video but why when we
did the video
mufti making it then you guys say
something like oh wow we're happy but
when we're doing
when we raised hundreds of thousands for
yemen for
fighting for our lives when we've done
you know charity tours when we've done
this orphanage made in this made a
school in india yeah you know got
something
we just you know so many places all over
you guys are nowhere
to be found that's what i'm saying you
don't tell the people like
wow look you guys be like this you know
guy like
because but when there's something that
i do you guys make it seem like oh wow
like
you know what i'm saying but i
understand i understand your perspective
all i'm saying is
for the future if there's anything i
would love to
you can hit me up now we'll speak about
it before you know what i said
um adam you know that's the reason why
you know i was literally when i was
speaking to your ex manager on that
isn't that easy was it
yeah yeah when i was speaking to him i
was saying brother please
let's sit down with adam i don't want it
black and you made a very valid point
no look from your point where i know
you're thinking who the hell are you
brother
like well like you are you the king son
who the hell are you i'm saying look
well i'm a nobody and i'm telling you
i'm not trying to be humble i'm a no one
i'm just saying my only concern is
the youth that are so that well i i wish
i could explain to you
they're so misguided that my that's my
concern it's not because i'm anybody one
why i'm nobody
i'm an absolute no one you don't need to
talk to me i'm a no one when you when i
when you spoke to muslim men you know
why i was so happy
because i said to myself after this i
swear to god if they
came and said to me that adam has done
this
i said brother
is a brilliant because they love him i
saw the examination i was like yo
like the way he was acting because you
guys take from i thought i would our
style is not working here
it's not working here so that's why when
you guys did that i was so happy
because that's a place that you can take
from and i wanted to meet in person
for that reason i don't wanna lie i'm a
nobody you don't need me no no no no no
no no
i'm not saying yeah we know you now i've
obviously i'm glad we know you because
you
do it is good to do that what you do
like with this the
the corner you know speaking in the
corner it's what you do i like what you
do
it's just it came as you said it's a
miss
communication and misunderstanding and
from the start it was like a gr
like a few of you guys that who had the
doubt word the name dawa and your names
and i would get
confused and stuff yeah but definitely
i would love to like in the future like
we can meet up
meet up and we could talk about it more
and definitely maybe even do
something for the youth because i do do
one every
every year me and slim we always want to
do something for the youth for
the muslims around the world we always
want to we always want to make a
statement and
and guide them the right way you know
there is sometimes there's a big mess up
or something happens or there's a
mistake
it goes out and we learn from it but we
still want to do good we still no no you
can you can
okay the thing is you know when this
thing came up about like you know what
happened yeah
on the tick tock here the people if i
was if i was asking i was looking well
if there's anything that i should have
jumped on it was this people were
sending me i said brother leave me alone
i said leave me alone because at the end
of the day they would watch you i said i
don't want to watch it
why are you forcing are you okay
i don't want to because i'm not there
looking for it i've done my bit there's
a certain point
till you can carry on character i'm i
can't be a parrot
in the context the only thing is the
private life
there's people who don't like you they
they want to see you fall
they work they are dying they literally
got binoculars and one
i'm not one of them i am not one of them
i promise you
i'm telling you adam i'm telling you all
right there's people that are
looking like with the binoculars anyhow
brother one
don't give them that your private life
look whatever it is actually look you
have your own struggles i have my own
struggles
we all do my private life you don't know
i
bro i might be doing some mad stuff yeah
i'm not saying i do
but i'm saying i might be but no one
knows because it's between me and my
lord oh allah forgive me that's why
abu bakr said when people come and
praise you
say may allah forgive me for what you do
not know about me and may allah make me
better than what you think of me because
you don't know me you only
think this of me of mercy of allah adam
wallahi don't ever let anybody make you
feel that you are a crab go in hell
wallahi these people anybody that says
to somebody you going to the fire
there's even a narration about somebody
who said to someone you're never going
to be forgiven
allah forgave that person and through
the person who said you're not going to
be forgiven to the hellfire
so i never think i'm better than you
don't let people take advantage of you
you know what really annoys me when i
get sad sometimes you know what it is
because when a public sin happen a
private sin is made public of any
individual
i get upset because you know why because
i'm going to have no choice but to
advise
people and i'm like i don't want to do
that because it
friction and i'm like man why did you do
this to yourself in the context of
these guys are going to take opportunity
your enemies are going to jump on it
people are looking for your downfall and
people come to me
and i say brother don't not one time i
called adam salva in private
or in public a name this guy is a
digital
this guy's antichrist this guy's evil no
he seems we sin yes there's mistakes he
makes
but adam i believe that's not you so aki
wallahi
don't let people take opportunity to
take you for a ride
and do your best while i you and slim
together you've got a beautiful brother
here
that is a friend when i saw the
intervention video above i was jealous
i was like mohammadi jab yeah and he
might do something
wrong yeah yeah like mohammed mashallah
when we went to
when we went to confront the far right
yeah the guy was down to
right you saw him yeah i'm ready to
fight and ready to die i was even scared
i was like yo this guy's crazy
yeah okay so the thing is he's here when
he was there with his gum showed yeah
because when we went in there but they
surrounded us he's a friend when i make
a mistake he calls me out
your brother you know you can't do that
he he tells me ali
and the reason we're doing this aki
because at the end of the day
we want the best for each other if i see
slim slipping
if adam sees slim slipping adam's gonna
come and stick on him
why because you care about him do you
get it so the only difference between
what slim and i did
was like same thing he had a concern
about his friend
and i know from your point of view adam
that he's a friend and you can trust him
me you don't know me you think this guy
doing it for clout or money i don't
blame you for that i'm so sorry
if it came across like the aquifer the
first five three videos i did i did not
make one p
i'm not here for the money i i
definitely i definitely know that i
understand right now in 100
i it's as you said it's a
misunderstanding or miscommunication and
i just really hope now we can
you know you know instead of doing this
creating this gap with the community now
we can
you know we can think of some stuff that
we can do to
you know to better the community you
know i'm saying where it is it could be
in america it could be in
in uk you know there's definitely a lot
even i i like the group that you're with
right now to smile too jenna i've been
watching
smile to jenna's videos from like a long
long time ago
uh musa adnan you know he's getting
excited
i remember him from a long time ago i've
been watching his videos from a little
while tell me about he's getting gusts
i've seen him make a video of uh of me
and then i i watched it no it was good
but
i like the little you guys are coming
like a group together and giving
good i like that a lot and that's why i
feel like we should do the podcast
and talk and just finally get to talk
you know because
i'm happy we finally did this
yeah adam what you can do from now on
look so i'll tell you something
i am i am willing to take all the videos
down about you
all of them i'll take all of them down
don't ever think the only reason i did
that
because i thought if some youngsters
maybe come across the video and think
that's okay
at least they can see a video that i'm
just giving a nasir to the person that's
watching
aki wallahi and i am a nobody cause i'm
a nobody
i i don't want you to delete none i
don't want you to delete none of the
videos i want you to keep that matter of
fact because if anyone
watches it they can as long as they when
i'm pretty sure they're going to see
this podcast and they're going to see
that it's all
like made up and they can learn from
from it you know you know
go back and watch it i want to learn
from it too so same thing
i'm definitely going to try my best and
and become
look at you know like like the face so
sorry so forgive me forgive me adam you
know what it is yeah
look you know your private life yeah aki
don't show it to anybody yeah i know
this thing yes
believe me we are all sinners but don't
ever look at us and think we've got
dawah in our name
we might be you know what's the
difference we just hide our private sin
but i don't
want to know about that that's peak if
people see it brother there's not ali
tower above that's ali ali refuted
yeah okay yeah so the thing is aki
well i the reason i said i'll take those
videos down because i don't want them to
be up
if sopano like positive changes you're
actually it doesn't need to be but if
you're seeing
for the the the timeline of what's
happening that's up to you any time you
change your mind
just keep it no no i think there's no
need to do this okay anytime you change
your mind and you say ali take it down
brother just
tell me it doesn't matter i think just
keep it
just keep it but but i'm just saying i'm
just glad to know as of now
like it's it's all love and i want i
want people to see that like
we knew we spoke and and we got to like
you know we got we want to plan on
seeing each other and definitely doing
something we should definitely do
something
when we come to the uk yeah we should
definitely pull it up
you know i mean food or something
yeah yeah no definitely honor to have
you guys i'll bring muhammad hijab like
his brothers and
wallahi like i said before i if i've
come across a certain way
one life forgive me but genuinely if you
watch my videos
i i never ever said you know doors are
closed
i fear for allah can you imagine i say
to those of jannah crows and allah
closes on me
and anyone that's watching this video if
you've backbited adam
he said he's this this is arrogance
it's satan you know iblees you know when
allah says we ask the angels to
prostrate and all of them prostrated
except iblees
iblis is made out of smokeless fire he's
not an angel he reached the ranks of the
angels
why do you know he please used to
worship allah everywhere
yeah do you know he was the most
knowledgeable yeah
the thing is his arrogance and his envy
envy his envy is what may work exactly
so me bro when i look at some of the
people i know their advice is not
genuine you're chatting nonsense
because for you to attack adam and call
him names and
how the child kafir how the hell are you
equating adam
adam is one billion times i wouldn't be
there's no comparison
so the thing is to call names you need
to feel allah because if somebody is
having
when i had mental like i was going
through some issues probably the last
thing i want to hear is people calling
me
calling me this and this and this and
this yeah it doesn't help
so the thing is fear allah there are
people who take their lives
yeah may allah protect us all so you're
actually bullying
if somebody takes their life because of
the words that you're uttering
and you're not seeing it because you
care you're seeing it because you want
to see his downfall
yeah that's what you want to do and a
lot of people want to see your downfall
at them yeah
people want one question you finish
yeah so don't give them the aki and
wallahi honestly i
i didn't know i needed this from you
coming from you it's making me
yeah it's hard to say but making me feel
better and making me feel more like
all my mental health honestly honestly
what you just said yeah make me feel
much much better my mental health i
would definitely not let them
you've got to get to me yeah you've got
so much potential
a lot of people pray they pray on your
downfall they want you
it's hard sometimes when you see so much
so much stuff like
messages of people just telling you this
so you're going hell you're not muslim
this and that
sometimes it pushes you away it makes
you feel like like just get
so angry and just lose it you know but i
i would never want that to happen i have
slim
i just said my brother who helps me out
a lot he helps me a lot
he keeps me he keeps me you know
sane he keeps me saying most definitely
and seeing you and
brother muhammad hijab smile to jenna
you guys you know killing it and coming
together i love that a lot it
reminds me of me and slim so keep that
up we definitely want you guys to keep
that up and
we should definitely meet up definitely
meet up in the uk you know we don't have
no um
no grizzly bear with us you know in the
uk we're free
so
where you live in uk london or yeah in
london london wherever you like how
comfortable wherever wherever
what where london was south north well
you're going to come to my house bro
enfield and food no what's that east
west north oh
no no no uh northeast north northeast
north east okay i just go by like
northwest because some people saw me go
south
yeah and we always stay north so it's
like yeah but i don't know the areas
like that okay but yeah definitely
yeah we should we definitely go there we
should definitely do something together
like
think of something that we can do to
make an impact you know not that i feel
like
[Music]
jenna and everyone we could definitely
do something yeah to definitely make a
big impact
for the muslim community we probably
don't know the idea yet but we could
definitely think of something like this
look look i'll be honest here sometimes
i get like um i'm overthink
i think a lot yeah sometimes i get
anxiety so you have positives and
negatives to that sometimes i'm an
overthinker
i get like you know mental health i have
that but the positive side is i can be a
bit creative
i can send like between we can just
share we can say look ali
brother adam you know this idea why
don't you try this out in new york yeah
bro go out like it's just i can say slim
bro there's this idea
just try it i'm trying to say it's it's
we work together like there's certain
people i contacted before
and i said brother look you've got a
massive platform look if you want and
this one was doing certain videos uh
attacking those who are attacking islam
i said bro i'll equip we'll equip you
with the knowledge yeah if you want to
refuse someone come and tell us we'll
send you bang bang bang bang bang
go for it yeah we'd just be in the back
i don't want no credit don't mention my
name
nothing as long as it's defending the
kalam of allah we're at your service
if you come and say ali i'm doing this
brother what do you need boom okay let
me prepare that for you i'll send it
don't give me credit don't mention me
because your platform is so powerful i
was watching your videos these five top
videos bro they're mad
i was thinking you you are adam dower
bro i'm so sorry i have to say that
no you're adam you're adam dow i'm so
sorry
seven miracles seven miracles of allah
bro come on
come on and then your quran in public
that guy the homeless guy was crying
that homeless guy remember that homeless
guy that homeless guy was like bro
i've been homeless and positivity
probably
i don't even know if that guy accepted
islam when he was praying and that black
lady came to
um i've got his name i think it was chef
his name was chef when he came to him
and he said to him
oh you know man she stopped crying i
never knew allah would
i'll be the last person to accept islam
brav i was like bro this guy is a
machine
the stuff that he was doing i was like
wow these guys don't know the potential
this guy has
is and and 16 million views
bro do you know how many people might
have you know i could definitely still
do like
even at the time i was doing a mixture
of videos like that and videos like you
know comedy videos of my family
and i still do it but the thing is i do
much less right now because
i feel like there's so much that i
already i feel like i did everything you
know yeah so
if there's anything else that i feel
like that you feel like that we can do
yes you know a video to to give darwin
that would fit for me and slim
let us know too you know definitely i
mean definitely you have your own style
definitely look muhammad hijab has his
style you know how boring the dao would
be if it was all the same
vishan smile to jannah he has his own
style mohammed
had his own style i have my own style
bro we don't need to be the same
and i'm not saying all your videos
should be tawa yeah
the only thing is people who are looking
for a mistake the private sin
close that door and after that bro you
your vlogs you're doing brother
what you're doing no one can say haram
you're doing a vlog you're doing a vlog
i'm trying to say so i don't want you to
feel like we're telling you rav you know
dude that you don't need to
you don't need to that's not you you're
doing your vlogs you're doing your thing
every now and then if you want to do a
video aki
you've got potential well why it's
amazing and
i i wanted to say that to you i didn't
even want to start this video and talk
about
that i wanted to speak about the stuff
that i love about you
you get i was because that is and i
didn't get a chance to do that i'm sorry
if
if i came across as i'm only picking
your fault
i genuinely didn't want it i accept the
apology
i forgive you and as i said i'm sorry
also for the names that
that i called you i i was truly just so
mad because everyone my own friends were
going
crazy i mean in my head all i was
thinking about you know
because people mentioning you so that
you're you're all over my comments
people saying this and that but
um yeah i apologize for that also i am
deeply deeply sorry and i really hope
inshallah
everything from now becomes positive and
i would definitely
close the door of you know of sitting in
public and trying my best to close that
so no one would
would you know come at me and say oh
let's head on this head i'm in chat you
know
praying for my downfall so definitely i
would learn from it and
as i'm i'm so glad you're here in this
podcast you you're definitely
what you're saying right now is
definitely helping me and i didn't know
that it's also gonna help a lot of
people too that's what's good about i'm
happy that we all came together as
brothers you know and like
just talked it out man like i mean this
honestly made me realize that wow like
miscommunication is really really
a big thing because after hearing
everything you said today i have
immense love for you brother well i
really do especially hearing about you
like you being a reaver and you want to
have to sneak around praying fagin and
stuff like
and honestly like gave me like so much
more love and respect for yourself
in the future future wise like you know
we're always we're just one message away
so if you ever want to reach out to us
you can just hit us up you know i mean
if you want to advise us on instagram i
know people are going to be confused
everyone keeps saying when is your
marriage documentary coming up
out of the whole world i never fought in
a million years adam silence is going to
ask me when my marriage talking to you
coming out
yeah this is it got me curious i'm like
what are you talking like yeah
everyone's telling me
yeah it's basically my search for
marriage so i documented it so all the
struggles that i went through because i
tested me with marriage very badly man
well take your time with it don't i know
and rush you you know
i'm just i'm just five years late that's
it it's it's not much no it's all good
it's nearly five years but there's
there's a reason behind it yeah but i i
in charlotte i want people to benefit
because it's my struggles in my haram
relationship to coming out from there to
islam
to trying to get married and you're
getting problems rejections oh you're
not from our country you're not from
here
you know and and it's so hard because as
a new reaver when you come from that
lifestyle
coming and for five six years bro i'm a
human being i'm trying to get married
yeah i need a woman in my life yeah and
hardship and hardship
and sometimes i do uber and i pick up
girls that are dressed very
inappropriately and it's it's i even put
a dashcam
because otherwise somebody accuses me of
some mad stuff yeah and
it scares me you know and and and i put
that because it was so hard you're
getting these girls getting in your car
and you're trying to earn a living and
it was such a catch-22 allah tested me
but
i'm happily married uh so like and
that's amazing
honestly you know we're excited to see
that i really hope you
do release that uh marriage documentary
real soon no matter if it's
a year or two from now but definitely
you in trouble you should
release it sometime soon um you know hit
us up whatever if you're ever in
new york or america we definitely want
to start something
positive we're planning we're planning
on setting up like what i'm wearing now
because it's our organization called
salaam it stands for sharing
affection love and mercy that's why
um yeah and we're planning on starting a
team in new york
um yeah we've got a brother there
brother esque maybe you know
we're talking we've got a few people
there inshallah uh we might start
something
on the ground because i came to times
square when muhammad had his debate with
that
uh scumbag sorry david wood yeah um
and he got destroyed yeah slapped his
face yeah
[Music]
yeah yeah so yeah
times square is is amazing and it's a
very good spot to give that with the
black israelites today and stuff like
that so we're planning on setting up
in sure if we come more than welcome oh
yeah yeah definitely
they go hard those people those uh
they go kind of they kind of crazy
people then they'll start talking about
stabbing people and like
guns and [ __ ] yeah yeah that's a matte
thing
yeah okay be careful with them they so
many times
even when we walk in we look like middle
eastern they like
call us out and then they want to
trigger us but i'm pretty sure you guys
can handle it properly with you know
with the right people but definitely um
yeah next time we meet inshallah
hopefully in person either in america or
in the uk
honestly thank you for your time for
being here in the podcast
it's a pleasure i'm pretty sure we could
stay here talking for much longer
but until new beginnings
i wasn't hiding behind the camera
uh you got you got a brother and us now
anytime
you could reach out to us any single
time definitely everyone may bless you
guys once again i apologize
if i came across anyway and i heard you
allah that wasn't my intention
thank you is there any is there any
advice that you can give me quickly is
there anything that
you would like me to maybe change work
on
please well i anytime no even if you
can't think of it now message me
you know yeah other than i just think i
just think just be more
no no i i think you do it probably just
be calm that's it just
just calmly yeah just be super composed
you know composed
that's all yeah just
for the black israelites in in new york
you know that's it
yeah anyways yeah that's all thank you
guys so much appreciate you guys
tuesday tuesday yeah yeah cool okay all
right
now i'm gonna stop the recording right
now okay i don't know
i'll quite record it from here all right
so